Okay, fangen wir an.
Okay, hallo, guten Morgen. Ich bin Erdemöse und habe diese Situation als Assistenastetik.
Ich bin jetzt auf der Stelle geöffnet und ich möchte mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschrieb
füllen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, Herr.
Okay, so erscheint erlische einige Fragen für Ihre persönlichen Daten.
Und dann sprechen wir über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden.
Okay, wie heißt es Ihnen?
Mein Name ist Helga Schmitz.
Helga Schmitz.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen bestabieren?
S-C-H.
Ja.
M-I-T-Z.
Okay, Frau Schmitz, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 50 Jahre alt.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ja, ich bin geboren am 22. Mai 1970.
72.
Okay, wie groß sind Sie?
1,60 m.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
95 kg.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Bäckerei Fachverkäuferin.
Ich verkaufe Brötchen.
Okay, alles klar.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich habe einen Mann und zwei Kinder.
Okay, Frau Schmitz, was kann ich für Sie tun, welche Beschwerden habe ich im Moment?
Ich habe Geländschmerzen, Muskelschmerzen,
Kopfschmerzen, Schwindel, Übelkeit.
Mir geht es nicht gut.
Ich fühle mich sehr, sehr schlecht.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ach, das ist jetzt schon seit November, seit Dezember habe ich das schon.
Okay, wo genau haben Sie diese Schmerzen, besonders frage ich.
Ich habe die an den Armen, an den Beinen, Kopfschmerzen habe ich.
Und Schwindel, dieser Schwindel.
Und ich kann auch nicht schlafen, wegen dem Schwindel und wegen dem Schmerzen.
Okay.
Sind diese Beschwerden immer dauerhaft oder gehen Sie auch wieder weg?
Immer da. Manchmal mehr, manchmal weniger.
Wie sind diese Beschwerden aufgetreten, plötschig oder eher langsamer?
Das hat zuerst hier am Arm angefangen, dann auf dem anderen Arm.
Und dann an die Beinen, das brennt manchmal sogar ein bisschen.
Aber ich habe als erstes Kopfschmerzen gehabt.
Und im Ganzen guck oder?
So hier rechts, da so eine Seite.
Manchmal auch hinter dem Ohr, rechts.
Bei den Händen oder bei den Finger oder Serien haben Sie auch Schmerzen?
Gott sei Dank noch nicht. Ich hoffe, das kommt doch nicht.
Das tut so schon sehr weh.
Und mit der Zeit haben sich diese Beschwerden verschlechtert oder?
Ja, die werden immer schlechter, immer schlimmer.
Ich muss jeden Tag auch Medikamente dafür einnehmen, aber das hilft nicht.
Was haben Sie dagegen eingenommen?
Liklofenac, Ibuprofen, Paracetamol, nehme ich gar nicht mehr, das bringt gar nichts.
Aber nicht geguckt nicht, ja?
Paracetamol ist überhaupt nicht, kann sich fünf Stück schlucken, bringt gar nichts.
Okay.
Gibt es etwas, das diese Beschwerden ja lindert oder versteckt?
Nein, aber wenn ich nicht schlafen kann, habe ich mehr Schmerzen zum Beispiel.
Wenn ich nicht schlafen kann.
Und Ibuprofen hilft auch nicht wirklich.
Aber ich bin verzweifelt, ich weiß nicht, was ich machen soll.
Sind diese Beschwerden mit der Lage, mit dem Essen oder mit der Bewegung verbunden,
beispielsweise beim Liegen, haben Sie mehr diese Probleme?
Also die Beinschmerzen habe ich abends am meisten, das ist katastrophal.
Manchmal muss ich aufstehen, manchmal muss ich laufen.
Aber ich bin auch sehr müde nach der Arbeit, das war ich früher alles nicht.
Sogar im Ruh haben Sie auf diese Beschwerden, ja?
Ja, manchmal ganz stark.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10, ein sehr leichter und sehr starken Schmerz?
Können Sie etwas sagen dafür?
Ich habe starker Schmerzen, das ist unterschiedlich, manchmal mehr, manchmal weniger.
Sieben, sieben vielleicht, manchmal kann ich es gar nicht aushalten.
Okay, haben Sie früher solche Beschwerden gehabt?
Nein.
Und zum ersten Mal kamen Sie zu einem Ast wegen dieser Beschwerden?
Ich war schon bei meinem Haus Ast, aber er findet nichts.
Er findet gar nichts, deswegen bin ich jetzt hier.
Ich bin verzweifelt, ich weiß nicht, was ich machen soll.
Haus Ast hat etwas gesagt oder eine Diagnose gestellt oder einen Mitkommen verschrieben?
Ibuprofen, wie gut man macht den nicht.
Ibuprofen, ja okay.
Ja, der hat Blut abgenommen, aber nicht gefunden.
Das muss doch irgendwo herkommen, das ich habe.
Ich muss doch eine Erkrankung haben.
Okay, alles klar.
Haben Sie Fieber, Schütterfrost oder Schweizer?
Nein, nein.
Sie haben Überkeit, aber haben Sie auch Erbrechen?
Nein.
Ihnen ist Schwindelig, aber haben Sie auch Rebussin verloren?
Nein, Gott sei Dank nicht.
Aber ich muss mich auch oft hinsetzen, wenn ich gehe.
Und dann muss ich mich hinsetzen, das ist ganz, ganz schlimm.
Ich war ja jetzt auch krankgeschrieben, ich konnte eine Zeit lang gar nicht arbeiten,
jetzt habe ich wieder angefangen, aber ich schaff das nicht mehr.
Ich schaff das einfach nicht.
Ja, okay.
Sie müssten immer krankgeschrieben werden, ja?
Ja, ich war jetzt vier Wochen krankgeschrieben, vier Wochen,
das war ich noch nie im Leben.
Aber jetzt habe ich wieder angefangen, aber es ist schwierig, ich schaff das nicht.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Ich muss sowieso Wasser lassen, weil ich Medikamente nehme.
Okay, haben Sie Herzprobleme oder Atmosprobleme?
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Sehen, Hörern, Schiprägen und so weiter?
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Okay, derzeit sind Sie im Klima, in den Wechseljahren?
Weiß ich nicht.
Nein.
Da bekommen Sie regelmäßige Regelbeutung?
Ja.
Und besuchen Sie auch regelmäßige Frauen,
oder Beziehung, falls Sie waren?
Ja, vor sechs Monaten.
Okay, war alles in Ordnung?
Es ist alles in Ordnung gewesen. Ich habe nur Myomö.
Okay, okay, gegen Myomö bekommen Sie eine Therapie?
Nein, die Hausjärte sagt, wir müssen erst mal nichts machen.
Kontrollieren, ja?
Genau, jährliche Kontrollen, hat sie gesagt.
Okay, rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich habe aufgehört vor zehn Jahren.
Vor zehn Jahren.
Und wie viel Jahre hat sie geraucht?
Ich habe so mit 20 Jahren angefangen,
20 Jahre ungefähr, habe ich geraucht.
Und eine Parkunkart pro Tag?
Das wollen wir unterschiedlich, also mal mehr, mal weniger,
ja, so 10, 15 Zigaretten am Tag bestimmt.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Selten, selten, also in Gesellschaft bei Geburtstagsfeiern,
aber selten eigentlich.
Was trinken Sie generell ein Bier, oder ein Glas?
Ja, manchmal auch mehr, also Bier, Gesellschaft trinken wir auch mal Wein.
Das ist eine Routinefrage, haben Sie mit den Drogen Erfahrung gemacht?
Nein.
Wie trinken Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen,
beispielsweise Bluthochdruck oder Blutzuckerkrankheit?
Ja klar, ich stimme Medikamente ein, habe ich ja gesagt.
Also ich stimme Blutdruck Medikamente ein, ich stimme Schilddüse Medikamente ein.
Gegen Bluthochdruck als nehmen Sie ein?
Und mit welcher Dosierung?
Dosierung habe ich ja gestern jetzt, aber Rami, Rami-Pril heißt das, glaube ich.
Okay, und einmal?
Zwei Mal, morgens und abends.
Das sind zwei Medikamente, da ist auch noch so ein wasertreibendes Medikament mit dabei,
da muss ich oft auf Toilette gehen.
Und erinnert Sie sich daran, welches Medikament Bier hat, wie viele?
Das sind zwei Rami-Pril, der Doktor meinte,
das wäre in dem einen Rami-Pril schon drin.
Und gegen Schilddüseinstehren passen die einen?
Ich nehme die Altyroxine ein, 175 Mikrogramm.
Hat der Doktor noch gestern letzte Woche erhöht?
Altyroxine, ja?
Ja, Altyroxine, 175 Mikrogramm.
Okay, sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Am Knie.
Ich habe einen am Knie rechts, das war aber in meiner Jugend noch, da war ich 18, 19 Jahre, habe ich einen Knieverletzung gehabt.
Und meine geilen Blasen ist auch aus, ich habe keine geilen Blasen mehr.
Und wann war das?
Das war nach der Geburt meiner ersten Tochter, das war so 1995 ungefähr.
Und waren diese Operationen komplikationlos?
Ja, ich habe so einen Schnitt hier rechts, aber alles okay, ich habe aber keine Beschwerden da eigentlich mehr.
Und ich würde fragen, ob Sie Hautveränderungen haben?
Ist nicht aufgefallen?
Ich habe keine Trottenheit oder Feuchtigkeit.
Meine Füße sind manchmal trocken, die cremig dann manchmal einer war.
Ansonsten ist mir nichts aufgefallen.
Ich arbeite ja mit Handschuhen auf, deswegen ist die Hand manchmal ein bisschen verschwitzt oder so.
Und dann fühlen Sie sich manchmal müde und abgeschlagen?
Ja, total, total. Manchmal bekomme ich den Haushalt nicht mehr eng, muss meine Tochter mir helfen.
Das ist schlimm, schlimm ist das. Ich kann nicht mehr.
Und sind Sie eingesetzt unruhig, bilänlos, teinnamlos oder Freudelosigkeit?
Ja, ich bin ja müde, ich habe meine Mann gefragt schon die ganze Zeit, warum kommst du nicht mehr?
Warum fahren wir? Ich bin mit dem Fahrrad, aber ich bin so kaputt, so müde, ich habe gar keinen Lust.
So war ich früher nicht, mein Mann sagt, ich habe mich ganz verändert.
Darf ich auch fragen, ob Sie regelmäßige Schlecksverkehr haben?
Oder Sie haben keine Lust mehr?
Ja, aber genau, ich will nicht mehr.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Gut, also ich esse.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewollt ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, ich bin gleich geblieben glaube ich.
Alles klar.
Und gibt es wichtige Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie, ich meine bei Ihren Eltern oder Kindern oder Geschwistern, wie Blutopterung oder Blutstückerkrankheit und so weiter?
Ja, meine Mutter hat einen Schlaganfall, die ist auch gestorben dann.
Und mein Vater, der hatte auch Bluthochdruck, aber der hat noch lange gelebt bis 85 Jahren.
Der Vater lebt noch hier?
Nein, der ist verstorben auch.
Ah, ok.
Öhren Sie mich?
Hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo.
Ok, über Ihre Familie haben wir auch gesprochen.
Und dann, ich würde auch fragen, ob Sie Missentfung haben, beispielsweise Krippen, Amäse, Laufen.
Öhnen Sie mich?
Eigentlich nicht.
Ich höre Sie, eigentlich nicht.
Ok, ok, frage Sie mich, das war alle meine Fragen.
Meiner Meinung nach habe ich alle wichtige Informationen erhalten.
Haben Sie Fragen oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Was habe ich denn, was machen wir denn jetzt? Ich möchte meine Altsleben wieder haben.
Mein Haushalt findet nichts, was machen wir denn jetzt?
Ja, freue ich mich.
Ich möchte auch Ihre Vital-Werte, beispielsweise Blutdruck, Fieber, und ich schreibe auch eine EKG.
Und dann lege ich Ihnen einen Zugang und nehme ein bisschen Blut ab für einige Bluttests.
Und dann kann ich wahrscheinlich einige Begründe verfahren, beispielsweise Röntgen.
Und dann können wir nach diesen Ergebnissen genauer sprechen.
Ok, das hat alles mal eine Haushalt schon gemacht, aber dann machen wir es nochmal.
Ich kontrolliere natürlich die Ergebnisse aus Hausarzt.
Und dann benötigt die Bluttests für die Isturche.
Ok.
Und dann, ja, sind fertig.
Dann komme ich zu Ihnen wieder.
Für alle Schritte informiere ich es.
Klar, ich warte dann.
Alles klar.
Erst der Geschebe sollen wir auch anfangen.
Oder eine Frage von Freunden.
Ok, gibt es Fragen?
Wahrscheinlich nein.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Heute habe ich einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich würde über diesen Patienten mit Ihnen besprechen.
Hätten Sie dafür eine kurze Zeit?
Ja, eine kurze Zeit.
Helga Schimitz, schuldigung, ja, eine neue Patientin, ja, weibliche Patientin.
Und Helga Schimitz ist eine 50-jährige Patientin und sei 72 geworden.
1,60 m groß, 95 kg.
Sie hat, ja, Adipositas.
Und sie arbeitet als Verkäuferin in der Bäckerei.
Sie ist verheiratet und hat zwei Kinder.
Seit November und Dezember haben sie Atralgie, Mialgie, Sefalgie,
besonders auf der rechten Seite und manchmal hinter dem Ohr.
Und Nausea und Vertigo.
Atralgie sahen generell an den Armen und Beinen.
Manchmal sind diese Beschwerden weniger und manchmal mehr.
Und auf dem linken Arm habe diese Schmerzen begonnen
und dann auf die rechte Seite gewandert.
Und diese Beschwerden seien prokredienter.
Und die Patienten haben sie über Prokran unter Paracetamol eingenommen,
aber nichts gebracht.
Besonders abends haben sie Choralgie.
Und nach der Arbeit fühlen sie sich müde.
Auch in Ruhe haben sie diese Beschwerden.
Die Frage nach vorherigen Beschwerden wurde verneint.
Und sie seien wegen dieser Beschwerden beim Hausarzt gewesen.
Aber Hausarzt haben über Prokran verschrieben
und einige Bulli-Tests durchgeführt.
Aber über Prokran haben nichts gebracht.
Sie haben ganz stark Nausea.
Und die Fragen nach Fieber, Schütterfrost, Schweiß,
Emesis und Beumsteinsveränderungen wurden auch verneint.
Außerdem haben sie keine Probleme beim Maske-Lassen- oder Schutulgang
oder Herz- und Lungen.
Und sie besuchen regelmäßig Frauenarzt, aber sie haben Miome.
Aber Miome wird von Frauenarzt kontrolliert.
Vor zehn Jahren haben sie Segarette aufgehört,
aber ungefähr 20 Jahre haben sie geraucht.
Als Parkungsjahr können wir 10 oder 12-Parkungsjahr sagen.
Alkohol hat sie gelegentlich.
Die Fragen nach Drogen wurden verneint.
Als chronische Erkrankung haben sie Artillerie und Schütterung.
Gegen Artillerie nehmen sie Ramepiril, Schweimal, Protak
und gegen Schütterung nehmen sie Ötropsin, 150 Milligramm.
Amkni wurde sie operiert mit 18 und 19.
Außerdem im Jahr 1995 wurde sie operiert
für Kolesisch-Technologie unter diese Operationen
Sajan-Kompikationsloses.
Die Frage nach Hautveränderungen wurde auch verneint.
Aber sie klackte über Fatigue, Willenlosigkeit,
Apathie, Aboli und Sexuelle in Appetence.
Die Frage nach Gewichtveränderung wurde auch verneint.
Die Mutter sei wegen Apoplex gestorben.
Der Vater hatte Artillerie und er sei auch gestorben.
Die Anamnese war so.
Aufgrund der Anamnese habe ich auch eine Diagnose für Hypothreuse
oder Fibromyalgia-Sendronen.
Um eine abschließende Diagnose zu stellen,
würde ich einige Blut-Tests durchführen.
Natürlich für die perlische Unversuchung.
Ich würde auf jeden Fall Vitalwerte kontrollieren
und dann Treut-Hormont-Tests.
Natürlich für die Anämnese würde ich auch Blut-Bild kontrollieren.
Leberwerte, Nierenwerte würde ich auch kontrollieren.
Und EKG schreibe auf jeden Fall.
Meine Massnahmen wären so sein.
Sie haben die Diagnose gestellt,
die Hypothreuse und Fibromyalgia.
150.
Was würden Sie erwarten in einem Labor?
Was würden Sie messen in welchen Parametern?
T3, T4 und Tsh würde ich auf jeden Fall.
Wenn beide Schilddrüse Probleme es gibt,
erwarte ich Reduzierung bei T3 und T4
und wahrscheinlich Erhöhung bei Tsh.
Und wenn Sie jetzt...
Primaeer Hypothreuse als sage ich so.
Aber für secondäre Hypothreuse erwarten man so.
Tsh ist auch niedrig mit Tdra und Tp.
Würden Sie das so belassen?
Oder würden Sie noch eine Untersuchung machen wegen der Schilddrüse?
Natürlich kann man auch ultrashal durchführen.
Er kann auch im Betrag kommen.
Haben Sie die Patientin gefragt, ob sie Schilddrüsenknoten hat?
Nein, nein.
Ich habe vergessen, ja. Aber ich kann natürlich direkt fragen.
Das wäre wichtig noch zu fragen, ob sie eventuell bekannte Knoten hat
oder ob der Hausarzt ultrashal oder der Radiologe ultrashal durchführen gemacht hat.
Und dann kann das natürlich auch sein.
Okay, absolut, ja.
Habel hat sich die Medikation verändert in der letzten Zeit?
Ich schildrüse Medikation. Hat die Patientin irgendwas erzählt darüber?
Ja, sie hat mir so gesagt, in letzter Zeit wurde ergriffen, die dosis von Erdtotroxin.
Aber von Erdtotrosiring habe ich auch nicht gebracht.
Okay, das müssten Sie noch mal nachfragen.
Absolut, absolut, ja.
Oder sind das dann typische Symptome für eine Hypothyriose?
Oder passt das Erdtofibromialgie, was Sie gesagt haben?
Was glauben Sie?
Hypothyriose ist eine absoluten Diagnose.
Man sollte alle Organischen sagen,
ja, alle Organischen sagen, ja, absolut, ja, schuldigung.
Ausschuldigende Diagnose.
Dafür muss man zuerst alle Organischen Ursaugen ausschließen.
Und dann sollte man auch darüber denken, ja.
Und was würden Sie denn, gibt es denn Blutwerte, die Sie messen können für eine Fibromialgie?
Ja, meines Wissens nach gibt es nicht.
Aber es ist ja auch eine Fibromialgie-Syndrom.
Ja, es ist eine Runde.
Wahrscheinlich, also es ist ja keine richtige Krankung, in dem Sinne eher ein Syndrom.
Ja, ja.
Also zusammen, Fluss von mehreren Beschwerden in dem Sinne.
Multisystemik, ja, multisystemik und keine Organische Ursache.
Genau.
Aber es gibt schon einige Blutwerte, die man zusätzlich vielleicht messen kann, um das auszuschließen.
Gibt es zum Beispiel, die Räume, Werte kann man machen?
Ach so, absolut, absolut.
Um zu gucken, dass das kein Räume ist, würde ich auf jeden Fall mitmachen.
Was wäre denn so die Therapie einer Fibromialgie, wissen Sie das?
Eigentlich ist das eine multimodale...
Wahrscheinlich hat die Patientin ja Schmerzen und möchte geholfen werden.
Ja, eigentlich ist das eine multimodale Therapie, braucht man dafür.
Und dann, ja, die Patientin, ja, oder der Patient mit Fibromialgie hat generell auch Depression.
Deswegen, als Medikament kann man mit Neodregardosis antidepressiver anfangen.
Aber nicht langzeitig, für eine kurze Zeit, man muss immer das kontrollieren.
Und natürliche Gymnastik oder Austraining und körkernliche Aktivität können in Betrag kommen
und mit psychiatrischen, körperlichen Massnahmen sollten in Betrag kommen.
Und dann, ja, Medikament, ja, bringt ja Püreschmerzen eigentlich nicht so viel.
Deswegen würde ich, wie gesagt, körkernliche Aktivitäten und Patienten, Patientenschulung ist sehr wichtig.
Kognitivtherapie ist auch sehr wichtig.
Ja, eine multimodale und mit anderen Abteilungen sollten diese Behandlungen organisieren, organisieren werden.
Wie würden Sie das dann der Patientin erklären?
Wie würden Sie der Patientin sagen, dass hier eine Fibromialgie-Syndromat?
Und wie würden Sie das Verständnis so erklären, dass es einfach zu verstehen ist?
Okay, nachdem ich alle andere Erkrankungen ausschließe, würde ich so sagen, ja, das ist ein Syndrome.
Und diese Syndrome sollen wir mit anderen Abteilungen, mit psychiatrieren oder psychotherapeuten zusammen organisieren.
Ich würde so sagen, das ist nicht lebensbedrohlich.
Diese Erkrankung können wir nicht total behandeln,
aber wir können natürlich kontrollieren diese Symptome.
Deswegen machen Sie sich keine Sorgen, keine lebensbedrohliche Erkrankung, keine organisieren Probleme.
Deswegen machen Sie sich keine Sorgen, mit der Seite können wir das kontrollieren.
Dafür gibt es auch einige Kliniken, Schmerzkliniken, so weit, bei denen können wir auch überweisen.
Ich würde so sagen.
Und Sie haben gerade von Antidepressiva gesprochen, welche Antidepressiva kennen Sie, die sich hier anwenden würden?
Ja, eigentlich SSR-Eig, beispielsweise Proloxet, Sitalopuran mit Niedrigerdosis können wir anfangen, ja, 5 mg Sitalopuran oder 10 mg Max.
Haben Sie gut gemacht? Sehr gut. Dann hoffen wir, dass wir der Patientin helfen können.
Ich hoffe auch, ja.
Vielen Dank.
Ich danke auch.
Martin, wie ist es in der Praxis?
Man kann z.B. Prigabalin, kann man Defintic machen, z.B. 2 x 75 mg.
Sie können auch Prigabalin anwenden, z.B. Lyrica, 2 x 75 mg, wenn die Patientin abendliche unruhige Beine hat, z.B. eine neue Part zu Schmerzen hat.
Aber der Beginn ist meistens mit einem, der Beginn ist meistens so mit Amitryptolin, wie Sie auch schon gesagt haben, Doloxetin, so etwas kann man beginnen.
Und wichtig ist halt bei frühem Pibromyalgia tatsächlich, dass man die Patientin schult und den gewissert, dass es keine schlimme Erkrankung ist,
sondern dass es eine nicht bösartige Erkrankung ist.
Und man lasst mit Psychotherapie, wie Sie gesagt haben, Multimodellertherapie, neurologische Behandlung, definitiv auch Behandlung kann tatsächlich, ja.
Also wichtig ist ja, mit Triptidien, Doloxetin, Fuchsetin oder auch Prigabalin, in manchen Fällen kann man sogar, wenn die Beine, also unruhige Beine sind abends,
kann man auch z.B. Eldopa nehmen.
Aber andererseits haben die Patienten, Partikuren und so weiter Müdigkeit. Und Sie haben keine Konvision, deswegen sollen wir darauf sehr achten, ja.
Greggabalin heißt.
Definitiv müssen Sie, definitiv haben Sie vollkommen recht, aber wenn Sie neuropatisch Schmerzen hat, wie Herr Gündus gerade gesagt hat,
dann müssten Sie die auch angehen mit Neuropatien. Können Sie Gabapenten oder wie gesagt, z.B. Prigabalin, Lyrica, definitiv auch benutzen, aber einschleichdetosieren,
weil das macht auch schnell mal wieder Schwindel und Bissines und so aus, ne?
Dankeschön.
Noch andere Fragen, meine Kollegen? Keine.